bonjour et bienvenue dans l'entretien de
france 24 que s'est il passé en france
ces quarante dernières années pour que
l'on soit arrivé à une société menacée
par un islamisme radical sur quoi ton
fermer les yeux qui n'a pas voulu voir
et surtout qui a financé certes il ya eu
les grandes attaques terroristes qui ont
éveillé l'opinion le bataclan en 2015 et
en 2016 le prêtre jacques hamel
assassiné en son église normande et le
professeur samuel pâtit décapité en 2020
pour avoir montré les caricatures du
prophète mahomet dans son court où il
expliquait justement la liberté
d'expression mais le quotidien repart
vite dans l'oubli d'un pays qui vit de
plus en plus séparés alain chouet vous
avez été au responsable pendant 35 ans à
la dgse bonjour merci de venir sur le
bateau de france 24 votre libre cette
pas vers l'enfer dresse le constat d'une
ignorance qui a écrasé toute lucidité
j'allais dire dans le pays quarante ans
en fait où on n'a pas voulu voir ou
alors on n'a pas su voir comment est ce
que vous expliquez ça alors là les deux
mon capitaine la sphère la sphère
commence avec la fin de la guerre
d'algérie où s'installe un hymne en une
immense incompréhension entre les
migrants du maghreb et la société france
est une société française qui se divise
en deux celle qui estime que
l'aspiration des musulmans d'algérie à
l'indépendance était tout à fait
raisonnable qu'on sait très mal conduit
avec eux et qu'ils ont tiré des des
droits des créances sur la france qui
les avait imprimé et puis une autre
frange de la société qui a estimé que
nous avions perdu notre seule colonie de
peuplement dans laquelle nous avions
instauré les lois françaises ces
départements français et c'est que ça
aurait dû rester à la france et que nous
n'avions perdu l'algérie que par une
sorte de tradition des militaires des
clercs et alors là on a eu deux
positions inconciliables qui ont fait
que ensuite il est devenu impossible
d'avoir un dialogue quelconque sur
toutes les problématiques
quelle qu'elle soit éducatives sociales
d'emploi et les terrains qu'ils
pouvaient concerner nos immigrants
venus du maghreb et là je voudrais
tordent le cou un peu l'histoire du du
grand emplacement l'histoire l'histoire
humaine est faite de migration de gens
qui vont à droite à gauche qui fuient
les guerres les conflits et qui vont
voir si l'herbe est plus verte on ne
fera pas l'économie de sun les
l'histoire humaine prend tir en sûrs a
est une affaire de migration notre
problème actuellement est celle d'un
certain nombre de nos voisins européens
c'est de savoir si une douzaine de pays
d'europe doivent être déversoir mondial
de toutes les migrations du monde mais
ça c'est pas un problème qui concerne
uniquement notre relation avec le
maghreb dont grands emplacements non ça
existe pas incompatibilité entre l'islam
et la démocratie ça n'existe pas non
plus ça c'est votre emploi aussi de
votre livre c'est de dire que finalement
cet islam politique qu'on pointe
toujours du doigt en disant si on est un
moment donné musulmans dans ces cas là
on fera toujours prévaloir la religion
au détriment du un pays donc de la
france ça vous l'a balayé où cela balaye
complètement parce que en 1945 tous les
tous les pays musulmans du monde était
sous statut colonial partir de 1945 qui
sont devenus indépendants pour la
plupart avec l'arabie saoudite a été
sous statut quo ligne et tous se sont
dotés de régime qui étaient soit des ddd
république parlementaire soit des
monarchies constitutionnelles
alors soit fonctionner de façon un peu
folklorique pas exactement sur nos
modèles mais c'étaient des régimes proto
démocratiques qui ont été ensuite
remplacés par des dictatures autoritaire
sous la pression
de l'affrontement est ouest mais avec
des régime militarisé qui faisait encore
moins de références à l'islam que que
leurs prédécesseurs et
les l'islam menée à bien montrer qu'ils
n'étaient pas du tout incompatible avec
des formes d'expression démocratique qui
est laid ce qui est incompatible avec
une forme
démocratique ce n'est pas l'islam c'est
le salafisme c'est à dire les studios
c'est dingue tu as fait particulière de
l'islam celle là où on va aller parce
que votre livre justement montre vous
êtes effectivement des renseignements
français vous avez observé dans
différents pays vous avez pu aller que
ce soit la syrie que ce soit le liban le
maroc vous avez été en poste mais aussi
l irak par exemple l'egypte voudrait
sillonné tous ces pays là et vous avez
vu se mettre en place un islam que ce
soit le courant des frères musulmans que
ce soit le courant du salafisme et là
vous voulez justement expliqué qu'il ya
eu une intention sur le d'agir sur le
territoire français un peu de sémantique
les frères musulmans sont des salafistes
salafisme c'est la lecture c'est la
lecture des textes sacrés du coran mais
aussi de la sounna
telle qu'elle était pratiquée pendant
les 30 40 premières années du califat
sous l'impulsion de deux mois mais dès
que les quatre califes ils longeaient
qui lui ont succédé après sa dérive
l'islam à partie et à partir des
cinquante années après le message de
mahomet commence à dériver à s'adapter
au monde qu'il conquiert à s'ouvrir et à
se libéraliser pour certains un peu
moins pour d'autres mais en fait surgir
de nombreuses d'école d'interprétation
dont beaucoup vont le sens dans le sens
de la modernité et ça on l'oubli au
tournant des années 1970 fin des années
soixante dix dans le monde parce que
certain nombre de pays réactionnaire
dans le monde musulman l'arabie saoudite
le qatar le pakistan aujourd'hui la
turquie ont décidé trouvé malin de se
réapproprier la lecture fondamentaliste
du coran pour imposer
une autorité absolue non démocratiques à
leur population alors je reviens sur la
politique actuelle ces pays ce qu'il
faut qu'on comprenne ces pays dont on
parle souvent sur france 24 nous sommes
une chaîne internationale donc on parle
souvent justement de l' influence de ces
pays que ce soit la turquie que ce soit
là saoudite on en parle dans d'autres
pays on en oublie souvent de parler de
la france ces pays clairement il savait
une politique qui voulait appliquer la
france et nos politiques on ferme les
yeux je ne ils n'ont pas non pas
délibérément appliquer une politique à
la france ils ont appliqué une politique
aux musulmans de france pas pareil c'est
à dire nous ayons chance ils ont
souhaité que les musulmans de france ne
soient pas tentés par l'aventuré
démocratique de façon à respecter
l'ordre théocratique que ont imposé je
mets une image c'est à dire que une
femme musulmane française sans voile ça
dérange ces pays naoui bien sûr et cinq
journées commencent à adhérer à des
valeurs qui pourrait éventuellement
l'amener à exiger le droit de vote la
démocratie
et c est que ça a été les premiers on
l'a bien vu dans les années 60 à la fin
des années 60 en france quand unis une
immigration de travail maghrébine
s'installer en france on a bien vu
l'intégration se faisait par les filles
les filles qui bossait comme des folles
allait au lycée vous voulez faire des
études alors qu'elle était des fois dans
des conditions météo extrêmement
difficile
et et qui ont pour beaucoup réussi moi
le champ pas on en parlait avec une de
vos collègues l'aude joueront en
regardant nos plateaux télé on voit
plein de jeunes filles issues clairement
de nominal de nos minorités maghrébine
qui ont parfaitement ici ça a été moins
le cas des garçons alors comment est-ce
qu'on est arrivé au fait qu'aujourd'hui
on a en france toute une population
musulmane française avec laquelle il n'y
a pas de problème la grande majorité oui
et comment est-ce qu'on en arrive à voir
dans ce pays des reportages qui font
l'actualité parce qu'ils montrent un
islam intégriste dans une ville roubaix
abandonné où on voit des commerces
effectivement de poupée sans visage et
donc qu'ils parlent clairement d'un
islam radicaliser bon alors toutes et
toutes les migrations qui a eu lieu vers
la france qu'elles viennent de pologne
italie tu les gens ont eu tendance à se
regrouper par affinités dans certaines
villes dans certains quartiers ou dans
certaines régions ça a été la même chose
pour
nos compatriotes originaires du maghreb
et dans certains endroits la wii
s'étaient regroupés ils ont constitué
une clientèle électorale que les
personnels optique français et ça c'est
fait la même chose en belgique dans un
certain nombre de communes en
particulier autour de bruxelles un
certain nombre de responsables
politiques locaux qui ont découvert qu à
y avait un bassin d'électeurs possibles
et qu'il fallait en faire plaisir là
dessus les agitateurs traditionnelle du
salafisme ce sont en particulier les
frères musulmans
direct sur le terrain que sont les
wahhabites de plus loin avec une
politique du chéquier puis ensuite les
qatari avec le soft power puisque ils
sont arrivés au long des jeux l'internet
fait des bonds par exemple tous ces gens
là se sont dit on va favoriser les
interlocuteurs française qui favorisent
ce notre stratégie vis-à-vis des
minorités musulmanes immigrées là alors
ni sur la fin de cet entretien la
responsabilité des politiques et les
très grandes finalement vous avez 40 ans
derrière vous d'expérience vous avez vu
des gens qui ne voulaient pas entendre
pas bien parler de ça c'est ce qu'on
appelle la bien-pensance c'est ça qui a
détruit la france oui cdc désespérance
seul le thème mon désarroi mais c'est
pas seulement qu'on n'ait pas voulu
entendre quelques chaussettes à clous
dans mon genre
dans le renseignement un premier malin
mais c'est que les alertes sont aussi
venus du monde universitaire du monde de
la presse parce qu'il n'ya pas que des
journalistes idiot vous savez qui ont
fait des enquêtes parfaitement documenté
et en particulier donc aussi de toutes
les recherches universitaires qui ont
été faites dont on a essayé de faire des
institutions et dont on a bien souvent
été empêchés comme il ya deux ans à la
sorbonne ou un colloque sur l'islamisme
le djihadisme et des pénétrations a été
interdite sous la pression des syndicats
à la jouer vous avez quitté la dgse vous
êtes resté un fin observateur on n'a pas
observé le monde pendant des années sans
avoir l'oeil aujourd'hui éclairé qu'est
ce que vous voyez dans la société
française vous écrivez ce livre
justement pour donner un legs pour
pousser les gens et dans une direction
jeu j'ai écrit ce livre parce que ma
crainte aujourd'hui n'est pas l'islam
isation de la france une absurdité ma
crainte est passé moi le terme parce
qu'il est vulgaire c'est des ratonnades
c'est qu'à un moment les populations
françaises dit de souche n'est pas au
goût de français touchent moi je ne suis
pas des populations française dit de
souche qui voit en permanence ce
spectacle que vous évoquez à roubaix ou
ailleurs sorte les fusils les fourches
et autres et que un assist à ce qu'on
appelait dans les années 60 des
ratonnades où on frappe à la distinction
entre nos bons arabes nos mauvais arabes
nos bons musulmans nommé nullement des
femmes les hommes et autres et ça c'est
ma grande crainte actuellement quand on
explique comme vous le faites dans ce
livre quand vous montrez le pied des
financements vous espérez éclairé vous
pensez que les gens sont encore capables
d'écouter et de faire la différence
euh non nos gouvernants savent
parfaitement à quoi s'en tenir là dessus
sur l'argent qui irriguent
alors ils cherchent là des solutions
voix bien
mais ils savent très bien d'où vu d'où
vient l'argent d'où vient la fluence et
comment éventuellement en négociant bien
pour essayer de s'en sortir mais il
faudra deux générations deux moins sûr
au mois merci beaucoup à la jouer pour
cet entretien bonne continuation sur
france 24 je rappelle le livre de titre
de votre livre cette part vers l'enfer
merci de m'avoir
[Musique]